some shapes roll in a straight line
some roll in a curve
[Music]
and some shapes roll in Peculiar and
seemingly surprising ways
but what if I told you that the strange
swaying of this particular shape is not
as unpredictable as it seems in fact
This shape has been designed to follow a
very specific path and according to new
research for almost any path that you
care to draw a shape theoretically
exists that can follow it
oh and this mathematical puzzle could
help give physicists a new way to think
about the quantum realm not just a
wobbly shape then
as a curious mathematical challenge for
a group of researchers
could they design a shape to roll along
any given path
the approach they came up with was quite
simple
take a sphere of clay roll it along your
chosen path and push down while rolling
it
[Music]
hey Presto the indentations formed will
lead it to follow that particular path
based on this principle the researchers
designed a computer algorithm that could
determine the precise indentations
needed to make any path
but an even bigger challenge was to make
it keep going tracing the same squiggly
line over and over again
for this to work the rolling shape has
to finish the path in the exact same
position that it started
the researchers modeled this by drawing
the squiggle over the surface of a
sphere
if they could make the starting point
the same as the end point then the
pattern could repeat
and using this method they were able to
come up with loads of interesting
rolling shapes far more variations than
had ever been invented before
but it didn't always work some patterns
just couldn't meet at the end
so they developed a workaround if they
could trace each squiggly path twice on
the surface of the sphere a solution was
much easier to find
this means that the rolling shape comes
back to its original position after
tracing the path twice
for this condition the algorithm could
design a shape for almost any path you
can think of so many in fact that it's
almost impossible to find an example it
doesn't work for
that's in theory anyway and with the
algorithm's ideal conditions but the
team wanted to be able to make real
physical objects that actually worked
with 3D printing it was simple enough to
create the precise shapes and inserting
a steel Ball Bearing in the center made
them heavy enough to roll properly after
that their problems weren't so much
mathematical as practical
in the real world sharp Corners proved
difficult though not impossible to
achieve
similarly paths that go uphill or cross
over themselves were a bigger Challenge
and they found that you have to have
just the right materials the right
friction between the surfaces and a
certain slope angle to make these funky
shapes roll their best
still by the end they'd come up with an
enormous number of new possible
strangely rolling shapes
why
well what started as just a fun
challenge could actually have some
potential relevance to other areas of
science
Quantum states are often represented as
points on the surface of a sphere with a
change of state being equivalent to a
path across that surface it's possible
that this quirky mathematical Discovery
could be applied to Quantum Computing or
Quantum Optics
but regardless of that right now these
researchers are happy to have shown
something no one else has before a
mathematical principle demonstrated in
the real world with a whole host of
surprising rolling shapes
[Music]